all of the matter and energy that
constitute the current Universe visible
and invisible is collapsed to well to a
point that isn't even a pinpoint it's
infinitely small and infinitely dense
and there's a cataclysmic explosion
that's the big bang that's still part of
the standard cosmological model still
and accepted the difference between the
early periods that you just described
maybe even in terms of fundamental
cosmological laws and later periods now
we might also throw in this caveat too
is that as far as I've been able to
determine it's still axiomatic
presupposition among scientists that the
laws of physics that obtained at the
point of the singularity are not the
same laws of physics or at least can't
be shown to be that govern the universe
as it's currently unfolding it's
actually better to start not with the
beginning which is ambiguous which is
hotly debated which is contestable and
those are all good things about the
scientific process but actually to start
with today so let's go back from today
when we think we understand the laws of
physics that that are presented to us
and go back in time to a point at before
which we don't understand the laws of
nature because if you start from a point
of ambiguity and uncertainty and then
you attempt to extrapolate forward
you're less likely to get the right
answer than if you kind of go back
historically and ask when do we lose
sight of the plot line when do we lack
our understanding of the laws of nature
so starting from today we see four
forces of nature there's two nuclear
forces called the strong and weak force
that govern the behavior of atoms and
radioactive decay and then there's a law
of electricity and magnetism that govern
everything from electromagnetic
communication like we're doing right now
to refrigerator magnets to magnetic
levitation and future helpful
Transportation mechanisms and then
there's the law of gravity which is
perhaps most familiar to us when we try
to get out of bed every morning we're
fighting against the entire mass of the
Earth with our meager masses hopefully
maintaining the battle every day to get
out of bed and make your bed in the
morning these four phenomena are
familiar to us and we can actually go
back a great distance in time and even
stay staying only in space where we are
right now let's take the Earth back in
time we go back four billion years the
earth condensed out of the shrapnel of a
supernova that had exploded perhaps a
billion years before that in our local
arm of the Milky Way galaxy let's go
back a few more billion years the dark
energy that we spoke about earlier began
to dominate and the universe started to
accelerate faster and faster well that
still is in the laws of classical
physics and quantum physics that we
understand let's keep going back now
we're back say 10 billion years ago the
first stars that were ever made are all
long gone they've all blown up into
these population three events that the
web telescope is hopefully going to shed
more infrared light on and then they go
back even further 100 million years
before that so now you're going back
from 13.8 billion years let's say today
we're talking on a Friday we go back
there's some Friday 13.8 billion years
ago if you just kept going back seven
times 24 and you just keep counting the
weeks and the years and the you'll reach
someday and and there'll be some day
that three minutes earlier the laws of
physics that we really understand know
and love gravity electromagnetism the
strong and weak nuclear forces that they
all froze into the configuration that we
can understand today
[Music]